This first statement is true. PCP is generally undecidable for 7 pairs of strings or more.
To see that you only need 7 pairs of strings to specify any computer program,
and that includes undecidable computer programs.
If PCP was decidable for 7 pairs of strings or more,
then you would be able to answer undecidable questions.
The second statement is not true.
PCP is not generally decidable for 6 pairs of strings or less.
That's because we don't know if we can represent an undecidable computer program
with less than 7 pairs of strings.
We might well be able to. We can't say this for certain.
This third statement is true.
Any SAT problem can be transformed into a PCP using 7 strings.
We might be able to transform it into a PCP using less than 7 strings,
but if we can do that we can certainly use 7 strings
and just not actually use them in our list of decisions.
By that same reasoning, this last statement is not true.
No PCP instance with 7 pairs of strings or more is decidable.
That's actually not the case, because you can think of a decidable program
with less than 7 strings or 7 pairs of strings,
and then simply add in more strings that you don't end up using.
This is perfectly acceptable. So this is not a true statement.